good morning John there's people with me
on a couch these are the creators of the
financial diet which is a website and
YouTube channel
let's talk about the personal finances
so I have some questions that have been
asked a lot of people wonder the answer
to I am also curious about this first
one is the better for your credit score
to carry over some debt on credit cards
month to month or just pay it off
completely it is better to pay off your
credit card balances in full if you have
the money to do so want to necessarily
like deplete your cash reserves because
and if an emergency comes up you'll have
nothing to tap into and this is a four
minutes show so most of this is probably
cut but for the record there is a part
of your credit quarter that is
determined by how much of your available
credit you are using so obviously
there's the argument to be made that
when you pay off a credit card in full
you are reducing the amount of credit
utilization as they call it which will
help your score but it is much worse for
your score to miss a payment right than
to have a higher utilization but if I
use all of my credit then that's not
helping my credit score you know that's
a bad fit so long story short better to
pay it off if you can but if you can't
pay it all off the most important part
is making that payment on time I still
have like a $3,000 credit limit and I'm
like what come on guys did you just me
that doesn't make any sense some
resources for getting started in
investing should I meet with a human
person or just go and Eitri
alright now listen up there is very
little regulation about who can advise
you with your money they could be giving
you bad advice or unqualified advice but
also when it comes to investment you can
start really really really small
obviously if you have a 401k it's your
job which many people do that is
investing but if you're thinking more
about like active investment there are
very very easy low-cost ways they don't
require you to potentially talk to a
snake oil salesman I would personally
recommend something like fidelity great
reputation they've been around forever
super low barrier to entry like you can
invest a couple hundred dollars a year
and you can do it all online really
quickly how do I eat less fast food and
also spend less money on fast food stop
driving by them first and foremost like
what we don't believe they're on all the
road they need an alternate route find
the ones that tend to the most and you
avoid things like the place also some
cooking at home
right like that is a nice guy or like
learn those copycat recipes yeah I'm
like - your favorite fast food places
how do I make a Chicken McNugget I'd be
investing in cryptocurrency no no no why
shouldn't i rack up my credit cards if
it just goes away what I do because all
these between now and we need to die
when they're gonna take your stuff away
when you get sent that bill and you
don't pay it like you'll start to see
those effects like almost immediately
don't come Rob you in the grave someone
was asking they're changing jobs and
their 401k is rolling over to the new
job and they were wondering if they
should just take their 401k out and pay
off their student loans with it I would
not know no the whole point of the 401k
is that it's a very good deal and your
student loans are probably at a fairly
low interest rate already it's really
nice to get that off your back and do
not have to worry about your loans
anymore but financially it's a much
better decision to just pay them off as
they come fast question why are jeans so
expensive depends what kind of jeans
you're buying though like are they
fashionable or are they just like
working versus do they have giant holes
on their Abercrombie I am a cool kid in
high school how dare you I will say
though that jeans originated as like
workman's clothes and they're super
durable and good pairs of jeans you can
wear for five years thank you people who
make jeans thank you except you forgot
some spots on mine thank you guys if you
want to watch more of the financial day
which you really should it's a
youtube.com slash the financial diet you
guys are on Twitter and you have a blog
and all that stuff as well there's links
in the description thanks for hanging
John I'll see you on Tuesday
endscreen check out the longer version
of this video that I edited for Hanks
channel and also a video I did called
six awkward money questions with Hank
green over on the financial diet